bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde on a devant
nous une épidémie qui arrivent les mots
d' emmanuel macron ce matin à l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière
la crise va sans doute changer de
dimension on s'achemine peut-être vers
un scénario à l'italienne alors comment
ne pas affoler les gens quelle est la
responsabilité à des médias qu'elle est
celle des politiques face à une
situation très évolutive coronavirus
comment en parler c'est notre grand
débat ce soir
id liban et de l'ibs théâtre de la
dernière offensive d'une guerre qui dure
depuis maintenant neuf ans et le bain de
sang dans cette région du nord ouest de
la syrie des millions de personnes sont
prises au piège les bombardements du
régime de bachar el-assad touche les
civils en priorité des civils les écoles
les marchés les hôpitaux des enfants
meurent même de froid sur la route de
l'exode
comment pêcher peut-on même empêcher
cette catastrophe humanitaire on en
parlera sur ce plateau avec nos invités
puis notre grand témoin ce soir est une
figure du débat intellectuel du débat
d'idées depuis des années figure
inquiète aujourd'hui face à la tentation
populiste la tentation autoritaire qui
monte dans le pays
il sonne la l'erc démocratique dans son
dernier livre nicolas baverez est avec
nous ce soir voilà donc pour le
programme suis parti à chaque cvr
n'oubliez pas on y va
on
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir nicolas
baverez bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
notre grand témoin on a une heure à
passer ensemble pour balayer les grands
sujets de l'actualité vous êtes
économiste essayiste chroniqueur au
point au figaro et vous signez
l'alertent démocratique
on va en parler dans la deuxième partie
de cette émission c'est aux éditions de
de l'observatoire met d'abord cette
épidémie de coronavirus qui gagne le
monde entier comment en parler c'est une
autre question ce soir quel mot quelle
place dans les médias bonsoir céline
pigalle bonsoir et bienvenue à vous vous
dirigez la rédaction de bfm tv première
chaîne d'info en continu de france vous
nous direz au fond comment vous
travaillez
comment vous traitez cette épidémie
informer sans paniquer les
téléspectateurs c'est un défi on en
parlera à concevoir qu'en avec dubost
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
député la république en marche de
l'hérault le premier ministre et le
président de la république 1 se sont
exprimées aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que dans la communication
voilà les choses sont sont pris en main
au plus haut niveau de l'état avec
peut-être des annonces dans dans la
soirée jean mais cia bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous vous êtes membre du
bureau national du parti de marine le
pen la présidente rassemblement national
qui était reçu comme tous les autres
chefs de parti à matignon ce matin enfin
bienvenue amélie le breton vous êtes
communicante cofondatrice de lagence
corio link merci à tous les 5 de
participer à ce ça vous regarde en
direct mais d'abord comment on n'en pas
justement dans les médias qu'elle ment
sont utilisés et bien c'est stéphane
blakowski qui va nous le dire dans son
billet si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
à tous bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien
compris ce soir s'ils ont bien compris
ce soir myriam une épidémie peut en
cacher une autre alors il ya une
épidémie comme on avait repéré
impossible de la manquer elle s'affiche
à la une de tous les médias c'est le
coronavirus lit d'un an mais il ya une
deuxième épidémie qu'elle est pointé du
doigt par le patron du ms monsieur
tedros ils appellent ça une info démis
pour lui l'info demis et une épidémie
mais à base de rumeurs infondées de
steak news en écoute bat nous ne luttons
pas seulement contre une épidémie nous
nous battons aussi contre une info démis
les fausses nouvelles se propage plus
rapidement et plus facilement que ce via
us et c'est tout aussi dangereux à ce
bundle voilà il vise d'abord les réseaux
sociaux évidemment mais c'est
compréhensible c'est quand même le plus
gros vecteur de fake news aujourd'hui ce
sont les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs la
plupart des géants de l'internet ont
pris des premières mesures google qui
est le premier moteur de recherche
s'engage est ce que quand on passe une
recherche au coronavirus ce soit d'abord
les sites officiels gouvernementaux
ouais mais ce qu'apparaissent facebook a
pris une autre initiative c'est à dire
de faire la traque aux publicités pour
des remèdes miracles contre le corona
virus donc il ya une action d'aidé de
ses géants mais le monsieur pedro s'il
ne parle pas que aux nouveaux médias il
parle aussi au vieux médias comme nous
la radio la télé tout ça on écoute nous
appelons tous les gouvernements les
entreprises et les organes de presse à
travailler avec lui pour alerter sans
attiser les flammes de l'hystérie des
flames of mystery
voilà comment informer comment réussir à
alerter sans attiser les flammes de
l'hystérie alors monsieur bruce à une
solution selon lui il s'agit de sonner l
alarme certes mais à un niveau approprié
truc c'est de savoir quel est le niveau
approprié et bien c'est pas d'un média à
l'autre on n'a pas forcément la même
idée de ce que c'est que niveau
approprié je vous propose de regarder
les unes de deux grands journaux qu'on
respecte qu'on lit voyez que c'est pas
la même approche de l'actu il ya la une
du parisien dans le métier on appelle ça
c'est plus catchy
c'est plus catchy parce que ça attire
l'oeil signalant les journaux sont faits
pour être plus donc on veut attirer des
lecteurs
remarqué en gros donc peut-être que ça
souligne le fait que les médias dans les
méthodes pour être catchy pour attirer
l'oeil ont parfois recours à la peur à
l'inquiétude alors montre des doigts du
politique vous les politiques
il ya des parties bas monsieur
vestiaires avant dans combien de fois la
nuit vous est instrumentalisée à tort
des français les médias parfois
peut-être aussi son sujet à ce reproche
est d'ailleurs il ya une archive leur
culte dans d'autres métiers
1 céline c'est comment un journaliste un
jour alimente la peur de manière
excessive que ça se passe en 76
roger gicquel le journal de 20 heures
sur tf1 un enfant vient d'être
assassinée on écoute tf1 20 heures avec
roger gicquel soir la france a peur je
crois qu'on peut le dire aussi nettement
la france connaît la panique depuis
qu'hier soir une vingtaine de minutes
après la fin de ce journal on lui a
appris cette horreur un enfant est mort
quand ça c'était il ya plus de 40 ans
stéphane le ton des jt un peu évolué
depuis évidemment aucune chaîne d'info
n'a un présentateur qui regardaient les
français en passant dix ans il y a eu un
premier port de l'aube du cornât virus
aujourd'hui la france a peur ce moteur
de l'inquiétude on a toujours tenté
d'utiliser donc on dit pas
la france a peur on se pose la question
on dit faut-il avoir peur c'est la une
du parisien par exemple n'agiront pas
qu'il faut avoir il ne fait que poser il
s'interroge mais bfm fait parfois pareil
elle dit pas on vous dit pas non on doit
avoir peur ou pose la question est ce
que il faudrait pas avoir peur donc
voilà ça inquiète un petit peu ça joue
un peu quand même sur ceux reçus mais
qu'est ce que vous donnez de la vôtre et
que les chaînes d'info attise la peur
mais non mais ce que je pense
ça va j'ai en tout cas enfin quand je
reprends tige est baptisé en tout cas
les flammes de l'hystérie ce qui est sûr
c'est que je n'ai pas du tout le
sentiment sans coronavirus peut-être que
je les ai eu un peu l'an dernier sur les
gilets jaunes mais bon je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il partie de la rédaction
de bfm c'était un peu plein en dix ans à
la direction ils ne pensent qu'à
d'audience en fait quand on regarde et
qu'on c'était une situation soit assez
inquiétante mais on pourra en discuter
par ailleurs répondre allez donc dire
que le coach et moi j'allais vous
défendre ce matin les frites c'est que
oui forcément ils sont numéro 1 donc on
est peut être plus sévère avec eux donc
je prenais un f1 événements cette
semaine le match lyon turin comment ces
traités en bandeau à l'antenne donc on
regarde et de son bébé bfm à gauche est
plutôt soft
enfin sobre en tout cas 3000 supporters
attendus sur lci c'est un peu différent
3 mais l'italien a lyon tout va bien
point d'interrogation vous dis pas que
ça va mal on vous demande juste
est ce que vous êtes sûr que ça va bien
donc ça c'est un peu les techniques d'un
faux mais c'est vrai si on fait monter
l'inquiétude on a toujours l'impression
qu'on va un peu faire monter l'audience
donc ça ça ça peut arriver surtout quand
on est outsiders comme ces news lci
cp c'est qu'on n'est pas dans la course
à l'audience lundi
mais pas du tout mais rien en nous mêmes
on doit faire notre propre propre examen
quel est le niveau de larmes approprié
je vous rappelle que aujourd'hui c'est
le troisième des vagues ensuite on fait
sur le corona virus sur lcc c'est une ne
sommes nous pas en train d'attiser
rivalin cela viable oui on se pose la
question céline pigalle merci c'était
fait il faut résister à ces titres
anxiogène on sent qu'on voit là on est
entré dans un moment compliqué et les
savait si c'est une question surtout que
se posent les téléspectateurs et si en
réalité en allant au devant d'inquiétude
qui existent d'interrogations qui sont
les leurs en était aussi en situation
d'y répondre et de les désamorcer
à côté tout à l'heure en loge que je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait une assistante
fameux tv qui était inquiète de
réceptionner les notes de frais de ce
qu'elle est rentré d'italie
ah oui parce que voilà parfois c'est
bien d'être rappelé à certaines réalités
il ya des gens il ya des gens qui
s'interrogent et qui ont des
interrogations qu'on peut balayer assez
facilement c'est à dire on peut répondre
à ces inquiétudes mais pour ça il faut
savoir qu'elle existe et faut les
prendre en charge les commandes
justement pour donc après j'ai entendu
qu il faut aller mal dire en mode la fin
du monde est proche
et honnêtement c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on fait ensuite évidemment aussi on
prend les questions les unes après les
autres elles sont titrés pour que vous
ayez envie d'écouter ce qu'on est en
train de se dire c'est aussi simple que
ça en fait vous avez un bandeau une
ligne qui suscite l'intérêt et qui fait
que vous avez allumé mais qui sont les
gens qui interviennent sur les plateaux
tous sont des médecins des experts des
responsables politiques et des
responsables des différentes
administrations qui sont en charge de
cette crise et est en réalité on ne fait
en permanence qu essayer de rationaliser
les choses même si on entend aussi et on
diffuse aussi les interrogations et les
inquiétudes du français justement
comment on trouve l'équilibré
vous avez une manière de travailler un
peu différente parce que la situation
évolue quasiment à l'heure au jour le
jour
vous avez dit à vos journalistes au fond
faites attention aux mots on voit bien
que chaque mot est pesé pour les
politiques ou au fond c'est une
information un peu comme les autres et
on la traite dans une chaîne d'info en
continu de la même manière quand
l'essentiel c'est une information
concrète comme les autres avec le même
sérieux et avec le sens de la
responsabilité qui en réalité nous est
constamment envoyé à défaut d'être un
service public
nous sommes néanmoins un service au
public en rond et donc c'est la chance
et la difficulté parfois d'être une
chaîne très regardée oui c'est que cette
nécessité de des gens responsables nous
est constamment envoyer ses dessous
simplement même que tous ceux qui nous
regardent en permanence nous alimente de
leur regard de leurs critiques et de
leur rappel à la règle il faut que
guerrier quel média on veut être lui on
va être écoutés donc effectivement mais
on a pensé très possibilité il existe
aussi une volonté il n'a une béquille
non on a le souci de choisir les sujets
qui vont être gardés
oui et de les présenter qu'ils soient
plus intéressant et c'est la différence
de se demander si ça répond à une
attente
s'il ya un besoin d'information sur ce
sujet et après évidemment il ya une
ils ont imaginé il ya un récit autant
tout ça mais c'est pas la même chose de
se demander si ça répond à une attente
est dedans samedi 20 février audiences
mais les femmes fait d'excellentes
audiences du million d'offres sur la
journée marc olivier fogiel qui est le
patron a rappelé face aux 28 c'est un
motif de satisfaction j'aime info d'être
le plus regardé possible et donc parfois
on se demande comment faire pour qu'on
me regarde plus c'est une des rares
existant
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais encore une
fois ce que vous vous appelez audience
avec le côté il faudrait immédiatement
qu'on se bouchent le nez c'est aussi
parler au plus grand dont vous parlez
aux plus grands noms en soit ça n'est
pas fautif est ce que vous êtes en
contact avec le gouvernement dans cette
période un peu particulière ou pas du
tout où avec le csa ou est ce qu'il ya
une volonté justement de de partager ce
moment un peu de d'union un peu
nationale ou de solidarité pour ne pas
alimenter que c'est trop cher de la main
directement sur ce sujet là de savoir
comment on traite les choses là au
moment voulu je me dis non il n'y a pas
eu de recommandations particulières du
csa je pense que le csa a dit souvent
que leur premier sujet c'était de
respecter la liberté de faire
d'expression des différents médias donc
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas constaté de
difficultés et de problèmes et donc
qu'ils n'ont pas souhaité nous
solliciter spécifiquement mais c'est pas
complètement exclu qui est des règles
qui nous soient transmises pour nous
dire faites bien attention à tel à telle
et telle chose nicolas baverez
je vous cite un autre titre alors c'est
la concurrence lci
on ne nous dit pas tout point
d'interrogation c'est dangereux de faire
ça est ce que vous vous craignez dans
cette période qui peut durer des
semaines des mois un emballement
je crois que si on quitte deux secondes
la france il faut quand même rappeler
l'histoire de de ce qui va devenir une
pandémie c'est à dire qu'au départ on a
quand même c'est né en chine
et le phénomène a été masquée par les
autorités chinoises on disait à juste
titre que les réseaux sociaux diffuse un
certain nombre de fausses informations
et c'est vrai mais il faut quand même
c'est grâce aux réseaux sociaux
c'est grâce aux deux maires et tu en as
su qu'il y avait
une difficulté et ce sont les réseaux
sociaux qui ont obligé les finalités
autorités chinoises à bouger il ya un
autre pays qui est dans une situation
aujourd'hui dramatique et où
l'information est complètement bloquée
c'est évidemment l'iran est donc ce que
ça montre c'est que ça c'est du côté des
médias c'est que la première chose si on
veut éviter de paniquer c'est quand même
d'avoir une information transparente
évidemment si maintenant revient au pays
comme les nôtres c'est vrai que ce qui a
été dit c'est à dire que les médias sont
dans une situation très interne et
d'hyères est très importante pourquoi
parce qu'on a un citoyen qui se posent
des questions et il a raison de se poser
des questions puisque ça va être une
pandémie et qu'il est normal de voir une
pandémie de se poser des questions
ensuite on a trois pôles qui sont deux
autres pôles qui sont bien différentes
les pouvoirs publics qui ont à prendre
des mesures politiques et les experts
les médecins qui peuvent donner non pas
la vérité parce que personne ne la mets
au moins donner les faits et puis d
interprétation raisonnable et les médias
doivent sont dans ce triangle et c'est
là où ils ont une responsabilité propre
c'est pas à eux de dire quelle est la
vérité scientifique ils ne l'ont pas
c'est pas à eux se substituer aux
pouvoirs publics mais c'est à eux de
faire en sorte que comme dans une
démocratie que les messages passent et
qu'on a effectivement la transparence
qui est fondamental parce que c'est la
meilleure manière d'éviter la panique va
venir justement elle à la communication
au gouvernement ils sont même moment
d'être enceinte sans basculer dans
l'hystérie surtout son véhicule et des
choses qu'on sait fausses alors on va
passer justement à la gestion de la
crise par le gouvernement les arguments
aussi qu'on entend monter dans
l'opposition un mot là-dessus pour
terminer sur sur cet aspect des médias
oui vous vous avez une vigilance vous
avez une crainte ou mais c'était un
terreau vous suivez ce que vous exposiez
sur est-ce qu'on doit aller au devant
quand on les médias allaient au devant
des interrogations du téléspectateur fin
de l'auditeur en général qu'est ce que
mon auditoire attend est ce que j'ai un
auditoire ou ou plusieurs
est ce que en quelque part en préjugeant
mais pas de façon péjorative juste pour
anticiper en préjugeant de ce qu'attend
l'auditeur est ce que je ne biaise pas
aussi sa réflexion sont des questions
qui sont infiniment éthique et qu'on
retrouve mais aussi en tant que
responsable politique
quand on prend une des
vision politique avec plusieurs options
sur la table vous prenez votre décision
pour répondre à une attente qui fait
plaisir ou parce qu'elle est juste et
elle risque de ne pas faire plaisir
pourtant vous savez qu'elle est juste à
long terme
donc ce sont des questions qui se posent
très régulièrement on est sur le coeur
des questions éthiques sur sur le court
aux navires us en particulier je trouve
que le traitement a été plutôt très bien
fait par l'ensemble des médias ils ont
été responsables ils ont relégué
vraiment les messages du gouvernement
on est quand même dans une situation qui
est sérieuse et où la responsabilité de
chacun à son niveau du plus haut niveau
du gouvernement jusqu'au geste du
concitoyen qui se lave les mains qu'ils
appellent le 15
s'il revient d'une zone de risque tout
le monde est important est le média est
fondamental dans la transmission du
message à ce moment là il ne faudrait
pas levé le biaisé je n'ai pas vues
biaisées
alors elle madame un sens on va passer
la transmission du message par les
politiques
ceux qui gouvernent ceux qui sont élus
ou dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui je disais à edouard philippe
a appelé tous les acteurs
les médias les élus à ne pas jouer sur
les peurs il a reçu donc les chefs de
partis et les chefs de groupes
parlementaires à matignon à l'arrivée
tout le monde était d'accord ou presque
regardez ces signes et nathalie guillois
il n'est pas nécessaire d'ajouter à la
crise un climat de psychose avons le
devoir de nous préparer au pire et en la
matière un principe de précaution
s'impose
merci de nous communiquer votre plan
d'action pour assurer la santé des
français
les oppositions appel à plus de
communication plus de transparence
ils s'inquiètent d'un possible manque de
préparation de la france face aux
coronavirus alors le premier ministre
edouard philippe a décidé aujourd'hui de
réunir les chefs des groupes
parlementaires mais aussi les chefs de
partis objectif l'unité nationale face
aux coronavirus sur ce sujet le calme la
mesure le bon sens ce sont des vertus
que nous avons intérêt à cultiver de
façon collective
il nous appartient ensemble
gouvernements élus nationaux et locaux
média experts de santé publics
d'accompagner nos concitoyens pour
assurer leur information et leur
protection
pour répondre à toutes les questions
qu'ils se posent sans jamais jouer sur
les peurs
les chefs d'opposition sont ressortis de
cette réunion convaincu et se montre
solidaire du gouvernement fauqué unité
nationale il faut tout simplement que
tout le monde soit mobilisé et puis
surtout il faut apporter des réponses
des attentes et notamment sur le terrain
et partout dans les départements on
ferait pas de ce sujet une polémique et
de la politique politicienne qui on a
besoin de notre aide
face au péril on sera là gouvernement
fait le boulot et je suis venu comme
d'autres ici la sueur et de notre
solidarité dans l'épreuve parce qu'il
n'y a aucune raison de jouer avec la
santé de nos concitoyens
seule marine le pen fait part de ces
divergences à la sortie de la réunion
elle se toujours une fermeture des
frontières je ne venais pas chercher des
éléments pour me rassurer
j'ai juste constater que nous avions un
désaccord et il me semble que quelle que
soit la situation des limitations aux
frontières ne s'effectueront pas à
l'issue de cette réunion edouard
philippe a évoqué une probable
l'épidémie en france
il appelle donc à la mobilisation et au
calme est-ce que ses responsables jean
metz il ya au fond de ne pas être au
rendez-vous de cette union nationale
aujourd'hui
il attendait qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'union nationale nous sommes dans un
pays démocratique dans un pays
démocratique face à une crise il ya des
parties d'ailleurs le 6 le premier
ministre les réunit c'est bien qu'il
veut aussi entendre la façon dont ils
appréhendent cette crise est la façon
peut-être donc il appréhende également
les solutions ça fait partie la
démocratie a pas d'une union nationale
c'est pas tout le monde au garde-à-vous
derrière le gouvernement c'est à dire on
a droit d'exprimer des critiques
j'ajoute que le gouvernement semble
depuis le début effectivement courir un
peu après les événements
ce qu'il appelait hier jouer avec les
peurs devient aujourd'hui une réalité
hier lorsque nous disions qu'il y avait
un risque d'épidémie on nous disait vous
agiter les peurs
je constate que maintenant le
gouvernement reprend exactement le même
terme en dix ans la reine levens d'abord
demandé la fermeture des frontières et
sur des contrôles aux frontières elle a
pas demandé la fermeture des frontières
de la frontière avec 'the il ya une
différente en dés il ya une différence
entre la humane compris nos biens
fermeture des frontières parfois mal
fermée l'affronter avec l'allemagne les
contrôles c'est au mail entière
belgique c'est ce à quoi la france sas
et des élites lcd contrôler les
contrôles sélectif par rapport aux pays
qui sont contaminés par le virus
ça c'est une mesure de bon sens parce
que jusqu'à nouvel ordre la grandière
cette maladie est né dans un pays et ce
sont des êtres humains par leurs
déplacements par leur voyage qu'ils ont
propagé
voilà pas fonctionné en état la face qui
avait beaucoup de contrôles en italie
n'est pas beaucoup de contrôles ils ont
jamais ils ont jamais suspendu les vols
avec la chine n'ont justement pas tous
et doté alors attendez juste juste une
si jamais il n'avait pas fait ça on eût
aimé savoir qu'elle aurait été l'ampleur
de la crise aujourd'hui ce que je
parlais ce qui fait qu'un certain nombre
de passagers ont voulu rentrer quand
même secret des correspondances donc
avait aucun moyen donc de les filtrer et
aucun moyen de les identifier mais
attendez donc ils se sont trouvés
dépassé en roulant mais peu de problèmes
sous le tapis alors que les germes et
les problèmes quand on sait qui tu
arrives et d'où il vient et qu'on peut
le suivre mais prendre une mesure ne
permet pas forcément de l'oedème
d'annuler le problème ici des gens
pouvaient régler une partie du problème
ça serait pas mal je finis juste ma
phrase en disant que en fait il ya une
espèce de perturbation du système actuel
à la fois les médias les politiques etc
parce que ça fait quarante ans qu'on
nous dit que tout ce qui vient de
l'extérieur est nécessairement positifs
tout ce qui est importé est positif la
mondialisation c'est la modération
heureuse d'accord et subitement la
création et non mais les coronavirus
jusqu'à l'ansé de la mondialisation
non mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre le corona
virus est un virus importé
alors je sais que depuis ce matin les
médias se sont précipités en disant nous
avons enfin pagne à sienne nous avons
enfin quand nous avons enfin une un
virus autochtones comme si on se
réjouissait qui avait enfin quelques
qu'on pouvait nationalisé le virus en
quelque sorte
mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est un virus
importé c'est la mondialisation qui nous
la porte est effectivement bon pas
maintenant parce qu'il ya un temps pour
tout huit fois par an la réjouit de quoi
que ce soit ah si j'entends depuis ce
matin dit roy le virus est un virus
autochtones attendait la personne qui
est morte elle a été contaminée par
quelqu'un qu'on va on va rester sur la
crise et la manière dont
l'exécutif la gérer le rassemblement
national a pointé des incohérences est
vrai qu'entre la journée d'hier on peut
se demander au fond pourquoi à nice on
annuler cet historique la dernière
journée de carnaval ou la fête du citron
à menton alors que le match a été
maintenu à lyon est-ce que la
communicante de crise que vous êtes
il voit une difficulté de lire les
décisions sur les quelques jours qui
précèdent et aujourd'hui une sorte de
voile à de volonté et de recentraliser
avec un maître mot la transparence là le
coronavirus faut se dire que c'est
peut-être un concurrent ou un opposant
ou quelqu'un qui va faire beaucoup de
mal à tous les politiques en terme de
communication pourquoi parce que on
maîtrise jamais à quel moment ça va
basculer les deux questions capitales
pour le gouvernement s'était laquelle et
la communication qu'on va mettre en
place et surtout à quel moment et pour
comprendre cette difficulté de savoir
quand il faut sortir pour pas être en
sûrs réaction comme a été l'italie ou
pour pas être à la traîne comme le
gouvernement l'a fait sur lubrizol je
devrais plus ou citer la ministre des
sports ce que je trouve qu'elle résume
très bien elle a été interrogé sur le
maintien du semi marathon de paris et
elle dit notamment sur les choix lit on
peut laisser planer un sentiment de
panique et tout le monde se méfie de
tout ce qui est finalement être très
éloignée de la réalité de la situation
et elle dit aussi ce qui fait peur c'est
l'incertitude autour du virus est pas le
virus lui-même il faut rester sur la
ligne de crête
elle a tout dit quand elle dit il faut
rester sur la ligne bern est un moment
donné l'approprier mais vraiment donné
il a fallu que la cellule de crise qui a
dû mettre un camion est mise en place à
matignon et à l'elysée se disent ok là
on est sur le bon timing il faut réagir
maintenant si on réagit avec 5 heures de
cinq heures plus tard l'opposition et
notamment lorsque vous avez parlé de
lubrizol
il ya un point presse on nous parle même
d'un point presse un peu à la manière de
françois molins ce qui faisait ses
points presse
après les attentats tous les soirs
c'était devenu un rendez vous très
attendu des français c'est ça que vous
voulez essayer de faire avec cette
transparence tous les jours et surtout
éviter au four les critiques de lubrizol
sur l'absence de transparence mais là en
l'occurrence la communication du
gouvernement elle suit surtout l'action
du gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on est
par essence avec ce virus et l'om est
cela dit plusieurs fois sur une
situation évolutive à l'échelle
internationale à l'échelle européenne et
hypothétiquement à l'échelle française
donc il est bien normal sur une
situation évolutive que nous tenions
informer les français de l'évolution
chaque jour puisque ça peut évoluer par
jour donc effectivement il ya ces
conférences de presse qui se tiennent
tous les soirs je pense que c'est une
bonne chose quand on est dans un
engagement de transparence de
responsabilité et de rationalité
parce que contrairement à ce que je
viens d'entendre monsieur ça n'aurait ça
n'aurait pas d'impact pour garantir la
sécurité de la santé des français que
d'annuler certains événements ou de
fermer les frontières avec l'italie si
c'était ce qui était demandé ou de
contrôler puisque j'en ai retenu salon
non pas du tout ce que je suis en train
de vous dire se laisser définir à ce
propos je vous ai laissé parler même
quand vous disiez des bêtises donc les
régions en italie les régions en italie
qui ont été infectés par le virus
elles ont été confinés parce que la
seule stratégie d'endiguement
scientifique qui existe ce ne sont pas
de fermer les frontières
ce ne sont pas d'empêcher des passages
aux frontières c'est de confiner les
gens qui ont été atteints il ya des
mesures drastiques ont été prises en
italie mais vraiment drastique
c'est-à-dire sont des villes entières
qui sont bloqués dont il ya pas de
provenance de ces emplois là si vous
sauvegardez provenance de ces villes là
et on veut transit en revanche mais le
match de turin c'était à plus de 200
kilomètres du premier foyer vous n'avez
pas de contacts directs ou alors on a
inquiété vous de ce qui se passe hors
chamonal et on a les moyens de confiner
par exemple des villes entières
s'il faut le faire nous le ferons
c'était pareil par exemple ce serait
possible
écoutez il faudra de toute façon faire
tout ce qui est l'agressé sander au
moment où ça se posera aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas à ce jour à ce moment je vous
parle ce n'est pas là n'est pas la
question n'en est pas là on est entre le
stade et on est au début on est au début
du stade 1 on n'est pas un stade
épidémique dont il n'y a pas ces
questions de confinement de villes
entières
se pose n'est pas impossible que ça a
évolué c'est pour ça qu'il faut dire la
vérité aux français leur dire on n'en
est pas là et et nous n'en sommes pas là
et si ça devait évoluer toutes les
mesures seraient prises et surtout tout
le monde est prêt tout le monde a reçu
et que la bride ses agresseurs massif
est passé pardonnez moi ce qui s'est
passé en chine c'est très impressionnant
en termes de confinement d'une ville
entière ou même d'une région houran le
roubaix on n'a pas évidemment le même
régime
c'est possible en france je ne dis pas
que ça va avoir lieu un mais est ce que
on peut dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre se demander aux gens de sortir
évidemment plus compliqué que dans un
régime totalitaire et c'est vrai que les
exemples de quarantaine dans des pays
démocratiques ça fait des siècles qu'on
a parcouru à ce genre de choses mais il
est vrai ce qui a été dit tout à fait
exact c'est à dire qu'en italie c'est ce
qui est en train d'être fait et donc et
pour l'instant c'est vrai que ça a l'air
d'être plutôt d'être plutôt respectée je
pense que ce qui se passe c'est que ça
correspond d'une certaine manière
pourquoi est ce que c'est possible parce
que ça correspond aussi d'une certaine
manière au premier réflexe des citoyens
qui est un réflexe de peur et de rester
chez soi et de ne pas et pour beaucoup
d'entre eux de ne de ne pas bouger pour
les polémiques sur les frontières
ce que je voulais je voulais rappeler
deux choses c'est à dire que on parlait
de un peu des guides que donnent les
scientifiques donc pour l'instant il ya
une autorité qui l oms et qui
effectivement n'a pas recommandé de
fermer les frontières ou d'interrompre
le msl même mais contre eux mais c'est
ce que je vais vous dire ce qui limite
c'est ce qu'ils montrent que c'est pas
une science exacte
c'est que l' oms à être de fait alors je
pense que les la période la plus
critiquable de l' oms est au début quand
visiblement sous pression de la chine
l' oms a massivement sous-estimé
ce qui se passait et donc ça c'est
quelques ça pose la question de la
manière dont on a laissé la chine
prendre le contrôle d'un certain nombre
d'organisations internationales dont on
voit aujourd'hui ce que c'est quand même
une autre leçon importante c'est que ce
qu'on a appelé le multilatéralisme donc
le fait qu'ils aient des organisations
pour gérer un certain nombre de raisons
de globo sanitaires environnementaux ou
commerciaux c'est quand même quelque
chose d'extrêmement important est qu'on
redécouvre qu'on redécouvre aujourd'hui
et puis il y à quelques surprises quand
on est en tout direct notamment sur les
chaînes d'info on va revenir à la visite
présidentielle à salpêtrière ce matin le
premier le président de la république
qui s'invite par surprise
là où un premier cas de coronavirus un
monsieur est décédé alors qu'il n'avait
pas voyagé et là il m'a regardé et que
kairos et le moment opportun et le
moment opportun pour le président la
république d'agir même dans une
situation dont il n'est pas responsable
c'est maintenant qu'il faut saisir et va
très bien j'ai entendu je pense que je
suis pas le seul
très bien mais méritait notre hôpital
merci que vous venez de voir mais il a
évolué c'est quand il appelle sauver
notre dame il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour être élu là il faut sauver
l'hôpital public qui est en train de
flamber à la même vitesse que d'autres
l'âme a failli flamber ça s'est joué à
rien et là en ce moment ça se joue à
rien
j'ai pas d'autres choses à dire sur vous
ah oui pourrait compter sur nous lambert
sera reste à prouver
non c'est une clique elle vous avez
diffusé en direct cette séquence
elle vient rappeler aux français que
l'hôpital est en crise
l'hôpital est en crise au moment où mal
sollicités au moment où il dit on est là
on est présent il est en crise on a vu
plus rassurant on a vu surtout un
médecin qui voyait dans cette visite
l'opportunité de le rappeler aussi de
façon relativement légitime puisqu'il
dit vous nous dites que vous comptez sur
nous il se trouve que depuis un certain
temps où vous demandent de l'aide
donc voilà on voit comment ce médecin a
utilisé d'une certaine façon une fenêtre
de tir et ce faisant il nous a tous
alertés et il a certainement lever de
nouveau quelques interrogations
honnêtement ce serait mentir que de dire
nous savons si nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à faire face pour la raison
évidente qu'on évoque depuis le début
c'est que nous ne savons pas tout à fait
comment les choses vont évoluer et sur
les questions du des principes de
précaution on peut tout faire
on peut dire on veut d'aucune manière
pénaliser les enfants donc on ferme les
écoles on peut dire on arrête tous les
voyages d'affaires après tout on peut
bien s'interrompre un certain temps on
pourrait tout dire sauf que la
difficulté c'est que il ya la maladie
d'un côté et puis à notre façon de vivre
habituellement et à notre économie dont
on peut pas complètement souhaité
qu'elle soit à l'arrêt et donc c'est en
effet cette ligne de crête
mais entre autres chefs d'ailleurs sont
dans l'abri et que tu es la question que
vous posiez de l'hôpital et ce qui s'y
passe alors là certainement ça n'est pas
le moment d'inquiéter sur leur capacité
à le faire jouer amélie le breton sur
cette séquence j'aimerais votre
votre éclairage redoutable pour le
président de la république qui vient
parler de la crise du courant d'un virus
et qui se fait rattraper par les
problèmes des hospitaliers il a eu de la
chance de tomber sur ce neurologue
s'allumant parce que il a utilisé cette
phrase vous pouvez compter sur nous il
avait un ton extrêmement paisible
extrêmement poser quand il s'adressait à
emmanuel macron lui serrant la main
comme s'il y avait un pacte de toute
façon entre l'hôpital français et les
patients qui pourraient venir même si
les mots étaient assez durs parce que la
réalité aller dur là-dessus ça
permettait de ne pas complètement
paniqué le téléspectateur ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la réaction d'
emmanuel macron il n'avait pas d'autre
choix que d'être extrêmement comment
dire très affirmatif dans le dans une
solution qu'il allait apporter très vite
s'ils voulaient se défaire de les
changes qui durait et qui était
contreproductif pour sa séquence il
fallait qu'ils disent je vais vous
apporter des solutions vous verrez vous
ne serez pas déçus pour avoir un écho
positif pour les téléspectateurs
nicolas baverez ce qui a été dit est
tout à fait juste à dire que c'est comme
pour le terrorisme le problème c'est la
résilience donc ce qui est idée juste il
s'agit pas d'arrêter la vie de la nation
le problème c'est l'inversé d'assurer la
continuité de la vie nationale dans des
conditions raisonnables tout en
protégeant au maximum la population et
c'est vrai que par ailleurs il ya une
crise de l'hôpital qu'on a laissé
s'installer et on mesure à quel point
aujourd'hui le fait d'avoir un système
de santé qui fonctionne est important
mais il ya bien d'autres services
publics on pourrait parler de la justice
ou d'autres qui ne marche pas donc on a
ces deux crises qui se juxtaposent et il
faut savoir que dans les crises c'est
vrai que l'événement nous précède
toujours et que ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir il faut néanmoins avoir
préparé des plans c'est fondamental
d'avoir des gens mobilisés et ensuite
une capacité d'adaptation et de réaction
parce que l'événement sera toujours plus
inventifs et il est plus bizarres et les
choses n'arriveront jamais forcément dû
de là où on les attendait et mais si oui
c'est joindre à un petit point de retard
mais si on ne s'est pas préparé
à la manière de l'est on sait qu on a la
certitude que ça se passera mal 108 au
prêt à recevoir les malades 200 millions
de masques commandés alors que les
entreprises sont en france j'en mets cia
le gouvernement met le paquet va même
pas qu'elle aurait fallu qu'il le mette
un peu plus tôt déjà et puis pour les
réquisitions de masques par exemple mais
je veux juste revenir à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est vrai que des
mesures effectivement de sauvegarde ou
de protection vont ralentir l'économie
c'est évident vont vont impacter notre
vie de tous les jours mais la question
c'est est-ce que le laisser pour se
propager le virus parce qu'on empêche ce
genre de mesure c'est pas plus graves
donc c'est toujours on est toujours dans
un dans un schéma en cure ça dans un
schéma de décision dans un monde
incertain quant à ce que vous disiez
madame sur le confinement vous pouvez
pas nous expliquer en même temps et
salué le confinement en chine en italie
etc en disant que c'était des mécènes ce
sont des mesures efficaces et venir nous
expliquer que lorsqu'il s'agit des
frontières internationales et les
frontières internationales sont
efficaces mais les frontières
internationales ne le sont pas je vois
je feins la bêtise je sais pas de quel
côté elle est franchement pas réveiller
avant le confinement et efficace et l'
isolement d'une région et il est humain
et dans ce cas là la finale ce soir
juste de donner à nos téléspectateurs
cette information qui nous parvient du
ministre de la santé olivier meylan une
augmentation significative des des cas
de contamination 38 personnes en france
donc sont contaminés principalement dans
l'oise
alors par rapport à ce que vous veniez
de dire je pense que c'est peut-être
compliqué à comprendre c'est peut-être
pas naturel peut-être que pour vous mais
laissez moi finir la phrase avant de
parler ne me suis pas sur facebook sous
quinzaine et un ton particulièrement la
situation s'est passé avec les soldats
un peu de respect pour leur chèque c'est
la marque du maquereau nice mais vous
avez une espagne histoire de laisser une
personne c'est oui mais parce qu'on vous
parler comme ça je suis désolé pour vous
je pense que j'ai alors dû temps on est
en démonstration exprimé le souhait
tenons soit vous êtes déjà dans une
posture totalitaire et vous me dicter
lui rend à la fois mes mots et montons
des halles pression les fans vous donc
au corps elle du jour mais merci jean
bessière les les frontières ne sont pas
les confine ne sont pas des frontières
de confinement et ça c'est pas politique
ces scientifiques les scientifiques les
médecins vous explique que quand vous
voulez
digg et quand vous voulez confiné
censure des foyers où vous avez beaucoup
de cas et où vous devez la isoler
complètement une région ce qui a été
fait en italie à partir du moment où je
crois qu'ils avaient 400 cas dans
certaines villes on n'était pas sur un
cas de cas douce car 400 cas quand vous
avez 400 cas dans une dans un village ou
dans une petite ville évidemment que
vous confiné et ça n'a rien à voir avec
des frontières nationales c'est vrai
j'en comprends que ça c'est plus facile
non mais je comprends très à l'esprit
c'est plus facile de se dire non on
ferme la frontière et tout s'arrête mais
ça n'est pas le cas pour que ça se passe
bien et pour protéger la sécurité des
français des européens
il faut confinés par zone de foyers où
ça serait pas une question vous avez
traversé pas mal d'épreuves depuis que
cette majorité est au pouvoir on pense à
la crise et gilet jaune la mobilisation
et les grèves sur les retraites comment
vous qualifieriez ce qui nous arrive là
c'est c'est le plus compliqué pour vous
à gérer ou pas non tout ce qui concerne
les français peut-être compliqué quand
vous prenez les choses avec sérieux vous
êtes toujours en responsabilité là c'est
le fait un phénomène naturel dirais je
c'est l'effet des choses très bien on
part exactement politique de la kadji
lulin qui a les moyens rien à voir mais
qui allait coûter cher on s'en souvient
on me dise où la santé il ya eu lubrizol
là c'est c'est très très important bien
sûr puisqu'il s'agirait essentiellement
c'est qu'il s'agit de la santé des
français
évidemment que c'est important mais tous
les sujets sont importants moi j'ai
confiance en mon gouvernement en mai
autorités publiques et surtout il faut
le dire quand même dans tous ces
médecins parce que on a parlé de la
séquence à l'hôpital la crise de
l'hôpital etc
moi je pense que quand le médecin lui
dit vous pouvez compter sur nous c'est
pas seulement un pacte
évidemment que c'est un pacte avec le
président mais simple c'est un pacte
avec tous les français c'est dans le
serment d'hippocrate
quand même il faut le savoir on a une
chance extraordinaire on a un personnel
qui est médicale qui est fabuleux en
france et il faut les remercier et ils
seront toujours engagés quels que soient
les conditions politiques ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faut pas se préoccuper de
la situation de bien au contraire et
vous savez qu'il ya un premier plan je
crois que j'en ai déjà dit plusieurs
fois sur votre plateau les 3 milliards
la reprise de dette peut-être faut-il en
plus loin une concertation et dans
l'urgence et de la jeunesse du camas
crise
voilà là on va
la gestion de cette information deux
patientes français sont dans un état
grave
elle faisait partie d'un groupe qui a
voyagé en egypte sans transition aucune
la crise du coronavirus vous savez un
cadavre n empêche pas les députés de
débattre de l'assemblée enfin presque
tous vous allez comprendre c'est le
point de retraite des tamouls un gars
pas tout de suite pas jingle au
pardonnez-moi faisait alors je le disais
donc où est ce qu'on risque on en est
dans les débats ce que vous savez que il
ya les retraites qui continue un député
manque dans l'hémicycle apparemment oui
c'est une information de l'express de
notre confrère de jean baptiste daoulas
un député priées de rester chez lui il
revient d'une zone à risque alors pas de
panique pas d'affolement c'est juste pas
le même protocole qui a appliqué à tous
les français bon on ne saura pas y
associer vous permettez je veux bien
répéter que pour tous les français
qu'ils reviendraient d'une zone à risque
il faut appeler le 15 le signaler il ya
un protocole qui est mis en place pour
mettre en sécurité à la fois la personne
concernée et tout son entourage
très bien je rappelle que l'egypte
jusqu'à présent n'était pas une zone à
risque on sent que ça se complique c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire alors où est
ce qu'on en ait sens dans le débat des
retraites
lda 11e journée de débat est-ce que
c'est toujours aussi tendue quelle est
l'atmosphère goûter toutes les deux
heures ça craque un peu c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui nous expliquait sa la
vapeur il faut qu'elle sort donc par
exemple ce matin et bien on parlait de
l'intégration des avocats des
commerçants des indépendants dans le
régime de retraite on débattait un peu
du fond toujours les mêmes questions de
l'opposition mais sur des questions de
fond et ça ça plaît pas du tout du tout
aux députés de la majorité ils sont
montés au créneau regardez moi je pense
qu'on ne peut pas tolérer que la petite
musique comme quoi un débat de fond
s'installe dans l'hémicycle là c'est
quoi c'est un ralentissement permanent
avec tous les sujets abordés n'importe
quand n'importe comment
ne faites pas croire aux français qu'il
s'agit d'un débat de fond
vous avez transmet vous avez transformé
cet hémicycle en meeting politique et il
est temps de le dénoncer
voilà les députés la république en
marché du modem ils veulent reprendre la
main sur le récit de l'examen des
retraites on avance mais on avance
difficilement
ils ne veulent pas qu'on dise
il ya du débat pour eux c'est du débat
canada dry ça ressemble à du débat ça a
le goût du débat mais ça n'en est pas
sauf que pour les oppositions c'est un
peu gros c'est pour préparer l'opinion à
49,3 réécouter cette confidence du vice
président de l'assemblée marc le fur il
est du parti les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame madame autun voilà tout est dit
il ya une déclaration d'un député qui a
suscité aussi beaucoup de réactions sur
les réseaux sociaux
oui ça va vraiment pas réconcilier la
majorité avec les avocats écouté sacha
ollier il est député de la vienne
lui-même avocat
pourquoi le nombre d'avocats va baisser
mais parce que précisément la profession
va profondément évolué ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui en contentieux de masse tu
n'existera plus parce que les
algorithmes et les font bien mieux que
les avocats ou là les avocats ils sont
très mobilisés contre la réforme des
retraites très mobilisés sur les réseaux
sociaux alors sur twitter il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions de
critiques contre cette sortie est ce que
le 49-3 passerez un peu plus inaperçu
regard du contexte de crise sanitaire ou
au contraire ça serait encore à l'est
encore moins bienvenue chez moi me lm je
n'aime pas les paris je les perds du
camp mais j'aurais plutôt tendance à
croire que l'opinion d'aller devant un
gouvernement concentré sur la crise du
coronavirus et pas forcément en train de
passer un petit 49 3 trous sous la table
merci ça m'intéresse d'avoir votre votre
éclairage votre analyse ce 49,3 danse
dans ce contexte il est il est bienvenu
ou c'est la seule issue au contraire il
va falloir en tenir rigueur je crois que
ça sera la seule issue parce que c'est
vrai qu'on voit très bien que le temps
de l'examen de ces dizaines de milliers
d'amendements fera qu'on on devra le
faire tomber un moment donné un autre
c'est une arme qui est dans la
constitution qui est à la disposition du
gouvernement
ensuite le problème c'est un problème
politique c'est à dire quel est l'impact
pour le gouvernement et est ce que il
est mise en oeuvre avant ou après les
municipales et quel est l'impact sur
l'actuelle majorité
ce qui me préoccupe davantage et ce qui
peut justifier cette guerre
d'amendements
c'est que c'est vrai que la méthode de
ce projet reste quand même difficilement
compréhensible à parlement s'est quand
même fait pour voter
la loi les textes les normes et puis les
financements les charges et donc l'idée
d'examiner quelque chose qui représente
14% du pip qui est fondamental dans la
mentalité des français dans le pacte
économique et social et de l'examiner en
dehors de la dimension financière alors
que vraisemblablement on va faire bouger
en plus un ou deux pourcent du pire hier
dans un sas pour moi c'est le vrai
problème que pose aujourd'hui plus que
le 49-3 c'est dans la chaîne alimentaire
dans votre ville et vous avez là
l'entrée du rencontre emmanuel macron
vous l'accusez de neutraliser le
parlement et même de l'affaiblir on peut
pas dire que le président de la
république ait eu un respect immense ni
pour les mêmes pour son propre parti et
pour le le parlement depuis que depuis
qu'il est en fonction
je rappelle simplement que même le
général de gaulle en 58 qui était quand
même pas réputé pour avoir pour adorer
et est vénéré ni les élus ni les partis
ni le parlement il s'est donné la peine
de créer un parti qui a structuré la vie
politique française alors vous pouvez
les aimait pas les aimer peu importe
mais il y avait quand même l'expérience
du et du rpf
ce qui est très étrange là et ça se voit
avec la carte d'implantation de ce parti
sur le territoire français il est
absente de l'essentiel du territoire et
donc ça c'est quand même extrêmement
étrange à dire dans une démocratie quel
que soit le dirigeant le fait d'avoir un
parti en grande partie hémiplégique et
même dans des institutions hybrides
comme la vème république qui sont à la
fois présidentielle et parlementaires
mais il faut quand même il ya une vraie
dimension parlez en à peine desserré à
cliquer peut assumer aujourd'hui la
députée la république en marche partie
du parlement que le concentration du
pouvoir présidentiel alors sur le parti
qu'il ait besoin à mi mandat alors qu'il
est tout jeune après deux ans et demi
d'exercice de responsabilité de ces de
ces jeunes élus de se remettre en
question et de voir ce qui fonctionne et
ce qui ne fonctionne pas oui pourquoi
pas ça me choque pas d'autant que c'est
c'est un peu le reproche qui avaient été
adressées au moment où en marche avait
été créé aux autres partis de dire vous
n'avez pas su vous remettre en cause
donc j'espère bien que nous serons en
capacité de se remettre en cause et de
faire le constat de ce qui fonctionne et
ce qui ne fonctionne pas pas de sujets
là dessus autre sujet non plus pour se
remettre en cause dans ce qui peut se
passer au parlement
me permettre d'atténuer un tout petit
peu votre propos en fait je considère
pas qu'on a une opposition qui a une
même méthode sur ce texte et ça se voit
très clairement des mystiques c'est pour
ça que le que marc le fur et les élèves
ne dirais pas la même chose
ils ont déposé deux mille amendements
ils ont déposé un projet un contre
projet ils sont pas d'accord avec le
nôtre ils ont le leur ils ont déposé ils
veulent en débattre c'est beaucoup de
mille amendements mais ça reste
raisonnable et c'est de l'ordre du
projet on a d'un autre côté gdr et et
les filles qui ont déposé de quarante
mille amendements
là on n'est pas dans le débat de projet
et là on est clairement dans de
l'obstruction c'est pas nous qui le met
en scène vous avez 40 mille amendements
des sous-amendements à tire larigot des
amendements qui sont parfois ridicules
changer annuel par chaque année enfin
pardon mais c'est pas les sens du débat
démocratique
donc de ce point de vue là oui à de
l'obstruction qui risque de gêner on a
beau essayer de faire des heures des
nuits des jours et qui risquent savez
peut-être à un moment d'arriver mais on
verra cela étant on a aussi une
opposition qui temps en temps nous
propose des choses on est d'accord on
n'est pas d'accord on en discute on
adopte des amendements
je préfèrerais n'avoir que des
oppositions dans cette posture là sur le
caractère finances j'entends que cela
puisse interroger effectivement que le
financement était confiée à d'autres
personnes mais je trouve que c'est aussi
quelque chose d'à la fois moderne et
respectueux dans l'esprit des grandes
constructions sociales que de confier un
équilibre financier aux partenaires
sociaux halde faire en parallèle la
démocratie parlementaire représentative
et la démocratie sociale
je trouve qu'au contraire c'est un beau
geste de confiance du gouvernement
évidemment je voudrais qu'à la fin les
mises en garde un peu de temps pour
battre les verts eelv est derrière moi
c'est à dire que le qui un temps de la
démocratie sociale oui mais il faut bien
que le parlement puisse examiner mon le
rendent la lecture mais vous trépignez
vous madame la prochaine fois vous
devrez faire invités politiques et les
poèmes et de faire de la figuration en
ce qui concerne le réseau national non
pas le mot de la fin c'est celui là
c'est que je proteste contre le
traitement qui m'est fait ici et
j'aimerais que la prochaine fois
lorsque vous inviter deux débatteurs
vous leur donniez exactement le même
temps de parole c'est un monologue ans a
été invitée politique
merci d'être venu sur le plateau des cp
on va parler à présent de ce qui se
passe au nord ouest de la syrie
vous restez avec nous nicolas baverez
vous le savez c'est un véritable bain de
sang dans la province d'idlib à la
frontière avec la turquie 298 morts
depuis le début de l'année le régime de
bachar el-assad donnent ce qu'ils
pensent être l'assaut final on va faire
le point avec clément pernot
c'est une guerre qui semble interminable
depuis près de dix ans l'armée de damas
affrontent les combattants rebelles le
régime croit désormais toucher au but
dans la province d'idlib près de la
frontière turque les dernières poches de
résistance sont présents d'entonnoir
appuyée par la puissante aviation russe
les troupes de bachar el-assad prennent
le dessus
[Musique]
les rebelles bien que soutenue par la
turquie cède du terrain lors des
précédentes victoires entre guillemets
du régime de la masse contre ces
rebelles et bien les rebelles qu'ils ne
voulaient pas désarmés ont été renvoyés
dans cette poche d'idlib qui aujourd'hui
est le dernier réceptacle le tout la
l'opposition à bachar el-assad faut pas
se tromper
bachar al assad est dans sa logique et
ils y arrivent progressivement et il va
y arriver je pense leur conquête
territoriale de l'ensemble du territoire
syrien et est donc la dernière étape
célèbre
persuadé de donner l'assaut final bachar
el assad fait peu de cas des civils son
offensive entraîne l'une des pires
catastrophes humanitaires depuis le
début du conflit sur place l'aide
humanitaire est dépassé il ya drame
humanitaire se joue neuf cent mille
civils qui ont pu fuir réfugiés déplacés
sur les routes
il a fait froid ces dernières semaines
il fait encore froid il ya des gosses
qui meurt il ya des écoles qui sont
attaqués donc il ya une situation
humanitaire qui est extrêmement
inquiétante dans une tribune parue ce
jeudi 14 ministres des affaires
étrangères européens réclament une
désescalade immédiate et appelle à une
solution politique
cette tribune ne sera pas celui des
faits parce que les ministres
signataires n'ont aucune influence sur
le terrain et c'est une guerre qui se
joue d'abord sur le terrain avec des
acteurs qui sont présents la turquie la
russie et l'iran et donc c'est une fois
de plus le constat de l'impuissance de
la communauté internationale dans cette
crise syrienne
si recep tayyip erdogan semble prêt à
négocier avec la dîmière poutine le
maître du kremlin lui paraît moins
pressés sur de son avantage militaire
sur le terrain bonsoir zidane à merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur vous êtes
franco syrien et vous présidez l'union
d'organisation de secours et soins
médicaux bienvenue à vous patrick
chauvel merci d'être là vous êtes photo
reporter journaliste de guerre vous avez
été de nombreuses fois en syrie vous
êtes réalisateur de nombreux
documentaires et je signale que vous
êtes en train de recenser toutes vos
photographies 3800 qu'est ce que je
raconte 380000 de vos clichés que vous
allez dédié au mémorial de caen on en
dira peut-être un petit mot mais d'abord
la situation sur place avec vous c'est
un bain de sang qui est en train de se
jouer
oui malheureusement la situation
actuelle vraiment c'est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe humanitaire qu'on
a jamais vu depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale déjà dans l'histoire de la
série depuis la fonte est ce qu'on voit
là maintenant l'aca dernier le dernier
mois
c'est la situation ne plus quand même
délicat on a à peu près presque près de
1 million de déplacés c'est déplacé
c'est pas la plupart parmi eux c'est pas
la première fois qu'il se déplace on
sait qu'il y avait avant des
déplacements de alep de dollars à damas
vers la région de heaslip et l'a de
nouveau ces gens là se déplacent
il ya parmi eux 80 % des femmes et
enfants qui se déplacent qui savent pas
où ils vont aller alors et expliquez
nous comment enfin on connaît maintenant
la façon de faire de bachar el-assad
c'est systématique on bombarde tout le
monde les civils il ya encore un hôpital
alors on ose parler de libre qui
fonctionne bon an mal an c'est vrai
avait des contacts avec les gens on a on
a des contacts avec les collègues
médecins là bas sur place nous dans
notre association soutient les hôpitaux
et les centres de soins primaires à
l'intérieur de la syrie dont le
nord-ouest de la syrie
et on a vu quand même et ces derniers
jours justement hier il y avait des
bombardements de sept centres parmi eux
il ya les autres plutôt y aller sans
doute à la ceni il ya un centre de santé
social
il y a quatre centres de soins primaires
donc il ya c'est quand même politique de
terreur on bombarde tous ces
catastrophes parce que suite à ces
bombardements là on voit quand même des
gens qui fuient ki ve ca proche sur les
frontières des frontières avec la
turquie sont fermées et les conditions
de vie c'est vraiment un type qui sont
ceux qui restent encore qui ne sont pas
parties et qui ont pris les routes de
l'exode vers vers les camps de réfugiés
ces médecins notamment qui continue à
soigner ceux qui n'ont plus rien si on
parle de l'équipe médicale abat sur
place vraiment c d euros qui restent sur
place qui vient qui qui essaie quand
même de sauver ce qu ils peuvent sauver
convient aps
et en même temps ils risquent leur vie
on sait que l'hôpital actuellement c'est
l'endroit le plus dangereux dans le
nord-ouest de la syrie
il ya jusqu'à maintenant des équipes
médicaux sur place qu'il veut pas
quitter cette ville pour soigner les
gens et les gens pia qui arrive pas à
fuir
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens qui montrent que c'est ça ce qui
montre combien le nombre de victimes
et on sait que ce qu'on avait là
maintenant hier et avant-hier les
bombardements deux hôpitaux les hôpitaux
à les marchés les échos
le voilà donc tous des taux tout ce qui
est tous les endroits de vie normale et
des bombes avant après que j'avais la
série ne fait pas la une des médias et
pourtant c'est un massacre qui est en
cours il ya ces visages portant qui sont
photographiés je pense à la petite
iman elle est morte de froid parce qu'il
faut expliquer aussi qui fait
extrêmement froid en ce moment dans
cette région sur sur la route pour
rejoindre les camps de réfugiés
il faut il faut les montrer ces visages
là il faut le refonder nom soit donné
bien sûr qu'il faut les montrer je
versais mois le métier que je fais et
que font tous les reporter c'est pour ne
plus jamais entendre on ne savait pas
c'est ce que certains allemands audi à
la fin de la deuxième mondiale s'était
plus ou moins recevables à ce moment là
mais aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas puisque
justement la presse est partout il ya
aussi les citoyens journalistes syriens
et irakiens qui font eux mêmes des
reportages sur ce qui se passe et donc
aux montres il faut montrer montrer
puisque si a pas de témoin n'y a pas de
crime donc amender va bien falloir que
quelqu'un réponde de ses crimes et le
crime peut être aussi dans dans la non
action il faut pour montrer il faut des
médias qui montrent est qui et qui
prennent des images est ce que vous
trouvez que ce conflit à la place qu'il
devrait avoir dans les médias
aujourd'hui les conflits n'ont jamais la
place qui devrait avoir parce que ce qui
fait tourner la presse c'est le show biz
et ce qui intéresse les gens c'est le
bonheur et je ne peux pas leur en
vouloir
mais ce serait bien qu'on parle plus le
certains événements mais on travaille
pas que pour la presse et un d'autres
endroits comme par exemple le mémorial
de caen où je laisse mes images et ils
ont créé un an maintenant non permanent
pour que les jeunes avec stéphane
grimaldi le directeur on a créé à meulan
droit permanent où il ya toutes les
photos les 380 mille photos des gens
plus jeunes les étudiants les élèves
pourront consulter ces images on pourra
alors parler de ce qui se passe dans le
monde et c'est ça qui est important
c'est il faut absolument trouver tous
les moyens qu'il faut pour parler de
cette histoire à travers les
documentaires à travers le cinéma à
travers
les journalistes il n'y a pas que le
journalisme de des grands médias
il ya aussi des livres il ya aussi des
documentaires mais aussi des émissions
il faut faire du jour toujours
maintenant c'est pas le premier
bombardement et alep et à la goutte a
maintenant cessé ses dribbles à chaque
fois on est saisi de l'impuissance
diplomatique de l'impuissance des
politiques c'est terrible alors c'est
l'impuissance des occidentaux parce que
via des états qui pratiquent une
politique de puissance notamment le
régime de damas mais aussi la russie et
la turquie qui d'ailleurs maintenant
sont dans des camps très différents je
rejoins ce que vous disiez c'est à dire
que moi ce qui me frappe
en tant qu'historien c'est qu'on peut
quand même faire une comparaison avec la
guerre d'espagne la guerre d'espagne ça
a été la même chose on a voulu détourner
le regard
ça a été le laboratoire de la seconde
guerre mondiale alors la syrie est pas
forcément laboratoire d'une d'une
nouvelle guerre mondiale mais en tout
cas c'est le laboratoire des guerres du
21e siècle parce que c'est une guerre
sans fin
c'est une guerre qui mêle le religieux
le politique la guerre civile
l'intervention des puissances
extérieures et surtout c'est une guerre
qui libère la violence de tous les
cadres qu'on avait essayé de l'installer
par exemple le fait que ont bombardé pas
les hôpitaux peuvent il ya toute une
série de règles implicites qui était
plus ou moins respecté mais là c'est pas
le fait que ces règles sont
systématiquement violés notamment par le
fait qu' on cible délibérément tout ce
qui peut permettre à la population de
civils de continuer à subsister pour la
casse et que la population civile
devient le premier objectif militaire ce
qui est quand même quelque chose qui est
tout à fait pouvant pas différent et je
crois que c'est ce que les démocraties
devrait quand même méditer c'est que ce
qu'on est en train de laisser faire en
syrie puisque maintenant les américains
partent les européens sont impuissants
de toute manière ça nous rattrapera un
jour ou l'autre
de même que ce qui s'est passé en
espagne nous a rattrapé un jour quand
bernard henri lévy dit que parler du
coronavirus au lieu de parler de la
syrie
c'est une énorme monstrueuse dit il
erreur de proportion cet accord bâle je
pense qu'ils aient failli qu'ils se
trompent parce que le c'est vrai que
dans une démocratie et quel que soit
dans un pays on ne peut pas ne pas
parler des choses qui qui qui touchent
directement les gens dans leur vie
quotidienne mais
ça n'exclut pas de parler du reste
d'essayer et d'expliquer pourquoi alors
que ça peut paraître loin il ya
véritablement il ya véritablement un
lien et quand on regarde par exemple on
parlait de la russie de la turquie ce
sont maintenant des démocratures essais
démocrature elle pèse directement sur
l'europe
une fois que l'une ou l'autre ou les
deux auront pris le contrôle de la
turquie de la syrie se trouve qu'elle
cherche à prendre aujourd'hui le
contrôle de la libye
aussi si ces états sont de ces deux
côtés de la méditerranée avec que donc
les deux verrous sur les migrants de
part et d'autre la position stratégique
de l'europe va être extrêmement
vulnérable donc gg dire là où je pense
que ça n'est pas exaucé qui a pas un
choix à faire on doit pouvoir parler des
2 et en expliquant pourquoi les deux
sont importants dit elle à l'esa on a on
a parlé des conditions où elle a des
civils qui sont atroces qui s'en vont
qui tentent de s'en aller ces
bombardements de la russie qui n'a même
pas voté la résolution pour dégager un
corridor humanitaire est idéal ces camps
de réfugiés où il ya des centaines de
milliers de personnes dans quelles
conditions vivent t-il les conditions
journalier c'est vraiment catastrophique
il trouve pas l'eau potable facilement
il n'y a pas des sanitaires il trouve
pas assez pour manger on en a entendu
quand même les enfants qu'une mort de
froid
donc il ya un manque du tout il ya un
manque du tout et c'est sain à ce qu'il
faut de travail et trouver là dessus
parce que le problème des déplacés qui
sont que n'ont pas traversé la frontière
avec la turquie qu'il reste à
l'intérieur de la syrie dont ils n'ont
pas le statut du réfugié et n'ont pas
inscrit sur le hcr donc il a aucun de
droit il n'y a aucun aide qui vient à
parler à ceux des associations
humanitaires
il ya un monde de thoune ou d'autres
associations on a fait des cliniques
mobiles pour aller jusqu'à se déplacer
et pour les suivre pour offrir des soins
gratuitement et l'on besoin des
médicaments de la nourriture
de quoi se chauffer des abris donc il ya
un manque énorme on parle d'à peu près
de nad d'un million de déplacés et bien
mille morts les derniers 3g de 30 jours
de plus un plan un début de l'année il
ya mille mots parmi eux il ya 80% des
près mes deux enfants
eric chauvel
vous retournez de retourner là bas c'est
pas tellement que j'ai envie mais je
dois retourner là bas parce que c'est
mon métier c'est ce que je fais c'est ce
qui m'intéresse
et en plus on n'est pas très nombreux à
faire ce métier vraiment je veux dire
est donc on y retourne sans arrêt je
pense que le problème là-bas c'est qu'on
n'a pas de moyens de dissuasion c'est la
dissuasion qui avait permis aux 60 ans
de paix en europe entre les américains
les russes etc
là bas il ya l'iran aussi qu'ils aient
pensé qu'un jour peut-être pas
aujourd'hui pour terminer on regardera
en face bachar al-assad et son peuple
un jour regarder en face c'est à dire
trois juges et il sera empêchée empêcher
je sais pas s'il sera jugé ou j'espère
bien en tout cas tous les criminels en
ex yougoslavie sont passés au thé pays
et c'est ça ou si grâce aux témoignages
des télévisions des journalistes donc un
jour il faudra bien qu'il réponde et si
c'est pas devant nous ce sera devant son
dieu c'est ce que m'a dit un enfant
syriens ont donné qui était mourant il
me dit je vous préviens je dirai tout à
dieu ce que vous avez fait merci merci à
vous docteur d'être venu merci beaucoup
nicolas vabrais vous alerter d'ailleurs
un contre elle et populiste populisme
les régimes totalitaires tous les
populismes d'ailleurs dans votre livre
vous dites même que la menace existe et
qu'elle est très forte dans notre pays
ils alertent démocratique et des
solutions aussi c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire et c'est passionnant
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis très
belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]